a young boy gazed in the sky wondering
what it means to be from the shy he had
a need to fly in search of his wings he
seek to rob schemes and also hoop dreams
saints and angels were seen songs of
what he could be he closed his eyes and
imagined driven into destiny you see
from where he stood he could see the
stars so he asked himself how do I get
to where they are if this city could
talk it would say hey man you from
Chicago the land of Fred Hampton and
Jean Baptiste Osamu and better
tomorrow's as long as you follow your
heart of the city a love the started at
Faust apart and Hooven out the dog or
even in the snow when we couldn't shoot
jump shots because of how hard the wind
would blow so we take it to the whole a
lot d-rose if this city could salt it
was safe from the concrete wheat rolls
a place of deep souls some ball is
street clothes nice with the shot but in
the pain we deep bones and coming from
shot city there's a lot they put up on
us but whatever they say they gonna save
you from the Tartars
if this city could talk it would say you
from the land of chosen children so
whenever you get on that Court
you carry the spirit of being Wilson and
the feeling of street legends whose
games we all cherish I'm talking Ronnie
feels Mack Irvin trash and Billy the Kid
Harris and legends of Chicago who are
basketball gods today like Mark McGwire
kg Isaiah and Tim Hardaway I said your
DNA if you can see you can be the way do
you know the story of the young boy back
in the day he was on a bus ride with his
sister not knowing where life were
taking chopped off to live with his
father at a West Side location now he
was a highly scouted but himself he
never doubted for dreams our
destinations you never know how they
could be routed and though the game was
crowded for himself he'd make a name the
world would call him flash this city
knows no master Wayne
he waited in the waters took over
quarters in the game became my MBA Great
Neck says the Hall of Fame what I'm
saying is if you love the game it
doesn't have a type you met this girl
when you was 10 years old
she'll be the love of your life let me
frame this picture for you on the court
drew an artist
you can be to the sport with dr. King is
to marchis
if this city could talk it would say go
beyond
Chicago's which you through the fire
just like soccer con if this city can
suck it we're talking ha MJ saw it on
air
six times six reams a city's answer
prayer how he jumped from the free-throw
line and dumped with his son now in the
88 all-star game when the New Jordans
was brung out bring them out bring them
out you'll bring out the best in the
Great's and inspire others like 23 did
480 you see he used his game to touch
the world so a key man Kobe Bryant who
wore purple and gold 24 hours a day
you'll put in work forget the salary and
being from Chicago you can process that
mob of venality
unless dedication and nice to fight so
even in the darkest times you'll feel
Kobe's light
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
have the audacity to hope and rock the
nation like Obama this is where he came
up you to have that comma and with all
that armor you'll still need others from
the mission remember for every joy
there's got to be a bitly
the city's sake listen
visitors taking flight
all these stars you see here yo Shawn
justice bright